this is the Schrodinger equation I know
it looks ugly but don't run away I'm
going to talk about what the Schrodinger
equation actually means and hopefully
you'll see it doesn't deserve it's bad
reputation see physics tries to predict
the future what it mean is if you have
an object in some state that you know
and then you do something to it you let
it go above the ground or you give it a
big push or you put it next to something
electric the job of physics is to tell
you what happens to the object next
Newtonian mechanics did a good job of
that if you know the initial position
and velocity of an object it will tell
you exactly where the particle is at any
time in the future in other words you
give it the initial state of the object
and based on the surroundings it will
give you the final state at time T what
we want for quantum mechanics is
something that will do the same tell us
what the future state of the system is
and that's what the Schrodinger equation
is for in fact there is a much nicer way
to write this equation that puts it
exactly into this form remember the
state of a quantum particle is given by
the wave function so if this is the wave
function at the start the Schrodinger
equation tells you that this thing acts
on it to produce the wave function T
seconds into the future then the
question is what is this transformation
and why is it that way if you're
interested in the history of quantum
mechanics then you may have heard Rodina
essentially came down from the mountains
with his fully formed equation with no
derivation this is kind of true but that
doesn't mean that there's no way to
motivate the Schrodinger equation these
days the main thing it comes down to is
actually conservation of energy it's
surprisingly straightforward but I
decided to put the derivation of the
equation into the next video see the
derivation of the equation and how to
precisely use it a good to know but are
kind of optional in terms of what we'll
do later however there is one fact about
the equation that is so vital we will
use it again and again in future videos
that one fact is so important that it's
all we need to understand quantum
computers
to prove the no-cloning theorem and
quantum teleportation and discuss the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics plus basically everything else
we're going to do so here it is time
evolution is linear let me explain that
suppose I have an object and there are
two different states I can start the
object in for example I could just drop
this object so it has no velocity to
begin or I could throw it so it has a
big starting velocity we know what would
happen to the object in each of those
cases right we apply a time revolution
to each and this is how they evolve but
now suppose my object didn't start in
one of these two states but actually a
superposition of both in this case it
both had no velocity and a big velocity
to start so what happens to it over time
what do you expect happens think about
it
hopefully what you expect is that it
will be a superposition of the evolution
of each of the states so at each point
in time the state looks like this the
mathematical way to put this is the time
evolution of a superposition is the
linear combination of the time evolution
of each of the states this is what I
mean if you have a state in a
superposition like this to get the
overall future state you just look at
the future state of the individual parts
and then add them back up it even holds
if you write up that same state in a
different basis for example if I change
to the momentum basis here the same rule
applies and so then these two states are
equal to each other they're both the
future state so the general statement of
linearity is this and this does seem
like a reasonable thing to request from
quantum mechanics but linearity has some
subtle philosophical statements about
superposition hidden in it look back at
this example it says that these separate
parts of superposition don't act like
they know the other part is there this
part of the object here doesn't look
over its shoulder and see that there's
another part of the superposition and
then decide to do something else
regardless of whether there is another
state in the superposition or not this
part of the superposition does the same
thing in other words anything in this
part of the superposition evolves
completely unaware of the other parts
well that is until measurement happens
when you measure the branches of the
superposition have the chance to
interact with each other again that's
because measurement doesn't follow the
Schrodinger equation this fact that
measurement doesn't obey the same rule
that everything else in the universe is
subject to is so bizarre if not
downright contradictory that it has its
own name the measurement problem and
it's the biggest foundational issue in
quantum mechanics meanwhile everything
else evolves perfectly linearly in time
unaware of the other branches
the superposition if you want to know
where linearity comes from and what
might have inspired the Schrodinger
equation in the first place click this
link to the next video